bene a tutti ragazzi e prende nessuno
video sono fatti j
ed oggi siamo tornati i suoi ragazzi
allora primo livello che vedo è il primo
livello zombie apocalypse bellissimo mi
rincuora che successo ma già da oggi ma
che belle mani che a lei rosa totti
pervertito non voglio provare il tuo
shampoo lorito francia anche un casco
chinino tienimi troppi i capelli guarda
che bastardo questa mia non ho mai visto
una posizione più sexy di questa frase è
diventata il mio casco mi ha [ __ ] il
casco alla mila jumbe razza di parma tv
ma niente non c'è verso le parole
ragazze non so come ho fatto ma non me
ne frega niente animati buongiorno io ho
fatto tutto il tempo poche parole io e
minaccio minaccio gli zombie così del
nostro non solo mito di i tuoi soldi
subito
ecco come non detto e roba si mai magari
le fosse molto aperti grazie ragazzi il
mio braccio non è una scusa scusa per il
bene amico mio non volevo e dalla barba
ma perché mi abbraccio se staccato di
precisi come non detto non voglio
saperlo luca su case e'caduto annusa le
mie scarpe lurido questa questa sarà la
tua punizione a vita sto continuando a
non capire che cosa cosa sta succedendo
visto di calcio io dovrei ammazzare
degli zombie si staccano le braccia saga
il piacere è tutto mio permesso molto
gentili grazie alla prima ecco perfetto
per il distretto 12 è una roba che
bellissima mira che ciò incredibile che
non si sarebbe fatta entrare ma va bene
così slow motion tre hard cos'è sta roba
gradirei un hamburger con patatine ok
facciamo meno nell'hamburger è
bellissimo essere serviti così negli
store ma che con il suo ragazzo vivo ma
sedia ok non sopravvissuto non fate
domanda perché ci sono tutti si sono
mosse non l'ho capito matrix oddio ma
che scriva ta della madonna
no non so scrivere un cazzo cioè io c'ho
il casco però non sarebbe una sega
perché non ferma neanche le lance non è
possibile lo racconti di morire nel tema
dio mio che mira pure tu lo sa perché ci
hanno tutti bene testicoli non l'ho
capita sta cosa
se sono solo diventare reporter credo ma
perché devo scrivere ma allora prima la
lancia ma il proietta 28 chiese ma
perché dovete ole ole mica un cazzo
signore e signori l'uomo che calciava i
proiettili possible 0,003 per cento
fanta cos'è il prossimo
amico mio come iscritto impossible sei
un genio di vedere cos'è sta roba
ragazzi perché devo andare là sotto non
è non è tanto difficile credo
un attimo prima
sì sì ecco mi chiamo ripreso il pogo in
aria non so come ho fatto non ho idea
ecco mi chiara tanto difficile one no no
ma perché in giro leggermente le balle
ragazzi sì sì ci ho messo degli anni per
fare sta cosa
si no baffo fi
ok ok
giuro che avrei calciato al monitor non
sto scherzando sul nostro segreto cos'è
che tace perché sto prendendo un obeso
oddio no mai attaccarsi un obeso con una
spada questa è la lezione che ho
imparato quello mi spiega ragazzi come
faccio a beccare grazie nonna
no perché le spalle mi servivano e se io
tipo ti alzassi a mo di danza classica
roba il lancio del nonno ragazzi sta
cosa è tipo uno sport lo farò passare
l'amburgo minuscolo t porca [ __ ]
sciacquati a [ __ ]
si no
ok non ho idea di che cosa l'abbia
colpito ma va bene così non apre devi
smetterla di non per i [ __ ] meno 3
per cento possible level cos'è sto
schifo non riuscire a fare tipo una roba
cosa cazzo è successo ma si faccia
beccare la pallina no fermi che allora
le mani si si si prega non si gioca così
a gocce però io i miei metodi per
assemblati bomb al trono non golf però
vediamo se riesco a farmi nativa ragazzi
mica che mira di che vittoria della
madonna pregate devo rifare un ospedale
come come cazzo fatto a vincere il
termine niente fare tipo così c'è una
roba tipo ecco perfetto però in più ci
ammirano ragazzi hachiko la mira sono
una cosa pessima non lo so perché è
perfetto se magari è la madonna che
esagerazione è questo che fa nei golfi
secondo per non le partite non lo so non
lo sapevo ragazzi cioè no al
maltrattamento sui golfistici tipo
dove sono obama e le sue medaglie subito
le voglio basketball cos'è la facciamo
una partita di bambello lanciamo i
bambini è certo mi sembra che ho anche
vinto io io lancio bambini a basket
vinco fantastico mi fate vedere che cosa
appena non ho capito io ho tirato un
colpo di pene che ha colpito luke troppo
epicità in una botta sola non è
umanamente possibile che ci sia riuscito
proprio il penny io faccio canestro ma
che bei bambini che vogliono giocare
quanto sono contento di giocare con voi
datemi un machete immediatamente lasciam
perdere sta roba perché ancora golf
ma quanti decenni ma questa volta riesco
a farlo bene subito anche se tipo non
spiegate che cosa abbiamo sbagliato di
preciso ok ok ok non ho fatto io non ho
fatto una sega però bene così roxy pro
mica era da mezz'ora che cercava un rap
sung ma non lo trova con un ciak
ma non c'è che non i safari rock swing
come faccio cioè una roba madonna che
mira dopo questa dopo questa voglio
voglio premi nobel tutto quanto
madonna non hamas è un fenomeno non
pensavo allora c'è un culo della madonna
o è un fenomeno e non lo sapevo anche
diventato uno slot trova di provviso non
l'ho capito ma va bene ma temi rimasto
solo un braccio quindi un po strana sa
cosa prova però fare in casa in perdo ok
se l'ho preso e andata di culo perché
potevo perdere effettivamente era
l'ultima spada avessi il tradimento e
cosa non devo lanciare le matite ma
perche l'hanno dato tanti compiti per le
vacanze a te finta che quel tizio sia
vostro insegnante tipo la roba del
genere cioè feld e la madonna jean
perdere comunque bello molto figo e se
tutto e sta cagando matite che ragazzi
come ci sono miliardo di livelli miei
che dai boss con il genio più di un
milione di iscritti camon barbie let's
go pardi
cosa ti sei fumato amiconi pochi gesti i
palazzi dove facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi
perché sono sono tipo spiderman vado sui
palazzi però col motorino perché io sono
più figo roba bello mi piaccia volevi
alla nostra luna di miele
un romantico perché io ti porto in posti
bellissimi però che cazzo di testa ho
vinto ti sei divertita piccola ragazzi è
stato fantastico per oggi sono tutti
slow motion cose del genere non lo so
ragazzi comunque ha tenuto bene piselli
ragazzi se il vino è piaciuto questo
momento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e come lo di 1.080 descrizione
se non sapresti discrete mi ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazzi